well what has been such a challenging
school year finally comes to a close
today it's the final day of classes for
the clark county school district
hector mejia live from the northwest bus
yard over at ann road in the 215 with
how the year's wrapping up good morning
to you hector
alex well without a doubt this was a
really weird school year for
teachers students parents their pets
really everyone involved and
back in august when school started we
weren't sure if these buses would even
roll out of the bus yard
when school started 100 percent online
students and teachers had to adjust
quickly to distance learning which came
with a lot of different challenges and
still
in march schools transitioned into a
hybrid school model that we have to
close out the year with
students on campus twice a week and
learning remotely from home the other
three days
some students and teachers won't have a
lot of time to rest though
free summer school starts tuesday for
anyone looking to catch up on
lost learning or credits and there are
two sessions the first is june 1st
through june 18th the second is june
21st
through july 9th as for the next school
year it's scheduled to start august 9th
full time and in person though ccsd will
continue to offer distance education on
a limited basis
the district asks families to make sure
they are registered now for next school
year
in high school graduations start
tomorrow and go all the way through next
friday
and here's one interesting thing to
highlight today is wednesday which means
distance learning for a lot of students
across the district that also means
they'll be closing out the year at home
in front of a computer reporting live
this morning hector mejia
8 news now